[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kai
selbe richter und christian sievers
guten abend inhalten es gibt keine
parallel gespräche
das ist der satz des tages die grünen
und viel überraschender noch die fdp
haben sich festgelegt sie dayton jetzt
gemeinsam die spd und niemanden anderen
mehr zumindest erstmal das ist mal eine
ansage nach langen tagen der
auswechselbaren worthülsen ist es auch
eine richtungsentscheidung mehr ampel
als heute war noch nie auch wenn sich
grüne und fdp eine hintertür offenhalten
natürlich frank buchwald berichtet
manchmal geht alles ganz schnell sogar
in berlin 10 uhr reichstag die grünen
haben eingeladen zum statement der
parteichefs sie hatten intern beraten
sagt annalena baerbock und sind zu dem
schluss gekommen dass es sinnvoll ist
jetzt vertieft mit fdp und spd weiter zu
sprechen ampel also hier seien die
größten inhaltlichen schnittmengen
denkbar sagt robert habeck denkbar heißt
aber ausdrücklich dass der krieg noch
lange nicht gegessen ist es gibt
erhebliche offene stellen und auch
differenzen das wissen wir das betrifft
natürlich sowohl grüne und fdp aber auch
grüne und spd viele dinge sind noch
nicht durch diskutiert die liberalen
folgen dann um kurz nach elf parteichef
lindner betont die eigenständigkeit der
fdp zugleich aber auch neue chancen
grüne und fdp sehen viele dinge sehr
unterschiedlich wir haben aber erfahren
dass wenn wir uns um verständigung
bemühen dass dann eine art fortschritts
freundliches zentrum gebildet werden
kann
und daraus ergibt sich viel fantasie er
habe olaf scholz angerufen sagte in
einer sondierungen zu dritt
vorgeschlagen am besten gleich morgen
parallele gespräche gebe es nicht die
spd sagt zu haben schon die gespräche
sehr konstruktiv gefunden die blätter
bilateral bisher durchgeführt worden
sind und wir sind auch sehr dankbar für
die sehr professionelle und ernsthafte
art und weise wie sowohl die grünen als
auch die fdp die bildung der regierung
bisher vorangetrieben haben jamaika
damit vom tisch
in der union wächst die enttäuschung
cdu-vize sparen gefragt nachdem
durchstechereien der letzten tage wird
deutlich ich kann nur sagen das ist
ätzend ist verantwortungslos ist es in
einer gewissen weise auch plump und
es ärgert mich maßlos
cdu-chef laschet wartet ab die hoffnung
auf ein bündnis mit fdp und grünen will
er noch nicht ganz aufgeben wir haben
signalisiert wir stehen auch zu weiteren
gesprächen bereit aber die entscheidung
mit wem man in welcher reihenfolge
spricht liegt bei fdp und grünen und
deshalb unser respekt für die
entscheidung wir stehen bereit als
gesprächspartner cdu und csu so viel
langmut bringt die bayerische schwester
nicht auf grüne und fdp hätten sich
entschieden sagt csu-chef söder in
münchen und die union ist auch nicht
jetzt nach einer so klaren vorprägung
das ersatzrad und nur dazu da quasi
immer ein gutes druckmittel zu erzeugen
in den verhandlungen und es wäre im
übrigen auch nicht angemessen gegenüber
union wenn man in so einer dauerhaften
warteschleife sich befindet das ist auch
mit dem selbst die selbstachtung würde
der union verbunden entschieden ist der
kampf ums kanzleramt damit noch nicht
eine ampelkoalition aber ist heute
wieder etwas wahrscheinlicher geworden
annalena baerbock die parteichefin der
grünen ist bei uns kommen vor der burg
hier in guten abend dass die grünen vor
allem die grüne basis stark richtung spd
tendieren das war klar die eigentliche
frage heute abend ist deshalb wie haben
sie die fdp rumgekriegt
lebst du in den momenten jetzt ja gerade
nicht so rumkriegen sondern ist eine
besondere herausforderung gerade für
alle parteien weil wir in unserem land
noch nie ein dreier bündnis gebildet
haben aber es liegt auch eben eine echte
chance in der luft für einen neuen
aufbruch gerade auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und nach im
wahlkampf wo man sich auch zwischen fdp
und grüne vertrauensvoll zusammen
gesetzt hat sehen wir gerade in der
gesellschaftspolitik dass es da einige
schnittmengen auch zwischen unserer
beiden parteien gibt auch wenn wir beim
klimaschutz noch einiges zu überbrücken
haben um uns und unser land auf die höhe
der zeit zu bringen und gerade mit blick
auf das wir ein einwanderungsland sind
auch wirklich neue chancen auszuloten ok
schnittmengen haben sie gerade wieder
gesagt konstruktive gespräche hören wir
immer dass das wort können sie
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile selbst nicht
mehr hören was heißt das konkret vor der
burg können sie uns allen den
wählerinnen und wählern mal ein beispiel
geben wo genau haben sie sich denn da
angenähert mit der fdp
ich kann verstehen dass manche sagen
mensch warum geht ihr zu viel und
vertrauensvolle gespräche aber in so
einer situation wo wir große
herausforderung in dem land haben
wirklich wie für eine modernisierung
gehört zu sorgen in der verwaltung aber
eben auch bei der frage große
transformation der industriegesellschaft
und auch das was alles liegen geblieben
ist in den letzten jahren ist es halt
wichtig dass parteien vertrauensvoll
miteinander sprechen und auch eine
grundlage schaffen dass wir die aufgaben
unserer zeit auch wirklich in den
nächsten vier jahren herangehen können
mitmenschen allem respekt wenn sie so
freundlich sind ich verstehe was sie
sagen und dass sie noch nicht ins detail
gehen wollen aber es ist handelt sich ja
um wirklich ganz große differenzen wenn
wir einmal ganz konkret ein beispiel
machen die schuldenbremse zum beispiel
sagen die einen ein die anderen sagen ja
steuern hoch sagen wir einen jahr sagen
die anderen wenn sie uns erklären
könnten was denn auf dieser grundlage
gemeinsamen schnittmengen überhaupt
heißen kann dass
loten wir jetzt in den weiteren
gesprächen aus deswegen haben wir heute
vorgeschlagen und die fdp hat gesagt ja
das diesem weg sollten wir jetzt gehen
uns mal zu dritt zusammenzusetzen
schüssen spd fdp und grüne und was sie
angesprochen haben mit der frage
schuldenbremse oder auch steuern hoch
und runter allen ist klar dass wir
investitionen in unser land brauchen
digitalisierung haben wir erlebt in den
schulen das kann so nicht weitergehen
aber gerade auch beim klimaschutz und
das bedeutet vor allen dingen dass hier
zwischen fdp und spd wo wir an den
punkten mit uns grünen auch auseinander
liegen jetzt gemeinsam dafür sorgen
müssen wie wir diese investitionen in
zukunft stemmen können weil ein weiter
so kann es nach den letzten jahren wo
sich so viel angestaut hat einfach nicht
geben haben sie den porsche fahrer
christian lindner von einem tempolimit
überzeugt
es geht wie gesagt jetzt nicht darum
sich gegenseitig zu überzeugen sondern
zu schauen wie man in den bereichen und
sie haben es angesprochen weil in der
verkehrspolitik
da sind wir zwischen fdp und grüne weit
auseinander in der vergangenheit gewesen
wie man jetzt die große herausforderung
dass wir auch den verkehr klimaneutral
hinbekommen müssen und unser
industrieland ins 21 jahrhundert gerade
in der verkehrspolitik zu bringen wie
wir das gemeinsam in einem dreierbündnis
angehen können und da spielt das
tempolimit eine große rolle aber vor
allen dingen auch die sicherung des
industriestandortes deutschland mit
blick auf die automobilindustrie und
darüber gegeben wie jetzt in den
nächsten tagen intensiv sprechen froberg
ich versuch's noch mal etwas anderes
eine sache die sie einen christian
lindner jetzt in den letzten tagen
schätzen gelernt haben
das wäre so offen und ehrlich gerade
auch über differenzen sprechen können
weil wenn man große herausforderung
angehen will dann schafft man es nur in
dem man bereit ist auch dinge mal aus
der anderen sichtweise zu sehen sagt
annalena baerbock grünen-chefin danken
für das gespräch danke
und hier ist der fdp-chef guten abend
christian lindner hallo guten abend ich
grüße sie herr lindner bei möglichen
koalitionen geht es uns um inhalte das
haben sie vor der wahl gesagt heute
haben sie gesagt die größten
inhaltlichen übereinstimmungen haben wir
mit der union und reden dann aber doch
erst mal exklusiv mit der spd dann kann
es ja doch nicht um inhalte gehen
doch es geht um inhalte wir haben eine
koalitionsaussage vor der wahl
getroffen mit der fdp wird es nur eine
regierung der mitte geben wir wollen den
wert der freiheit stärken und das gilt
auch nach der wahl allerdings kann ja
jeder verfolgen dass die union
gegenwärtig selbst diskutiert ob sie
regierungswillig und regierungsfähig ist
und aus diesem grund weil deutschland ja
nicht in einen drift geraten darf
sondern bald eine handlungsfähige
regierung braucht haben wir das angebot
die einladung den vorschlag angenommen
zunächst einmal jetzt zu dritt mit spd
und grünen zu prüfen ob es
gemeinsamkeiten gibt guter länder aber
das ist jetzt kein inhaltliches argument
sondern eine atmosphärische sie sagen
quasi die cdu/csu ist aktuell für uns
nicht regierungsfähig
es gibt keinerlei festlegung der fdp auf
einen ampel oder auf ein jamaika bündnis
sondern ganz ausdrücklich ist jamaika
für uns weiter eine inhalt nicht
tragfähige option
ich habe allerdings zur kenntnis
genommen dass die csu am heutigen tag
sich quasi aus dem spiel nehmen wollte
das halte ich nicht für ratsam wir haben
eine sehr komplizierte eine sehr
herausfordernde lage und hier sollten
alle demokratischen parteien weiter
miteinander im gespräch bleiben damit
unser land möglichst schnell eine
handlungsfähige regierung bekommt wir
dürfen nicht darauf hoffen dass die welt
auf uns wartet sondern wir müssen uns in
deutschland aufstellen umgekehrt könnte
man aber auch sagen sie müssten
eigentlich markus söder ein bisschen
dankbar sein heute dass er ihnen
geholfen hat umzuschwenken richtung
ampel die fdp hat keinen schwenk
vorgenommen wir sind eigenständig in die
bundestagswahl gegangen ich erinnere
daran dass cdu und csu ja sogar
wahlkampf gegen die fdp gemacht haben
wir haben eine inhaltliche
koalitionsaussage wie ich eben gesagt
habe getroffen und wir haben inhalte
markiert die mit der fdp gehen und
solche die mit der fdp nicht gehen
beispiele haben sie eben genannt
steuererhöhungen und ein aufweichen der
schuldenbremse da kann man nicht auf die
fdp zählen da die union in der situation
ist die sie ja auch gerade angesprochen
haben möchte ich ganz klar sagen dass
die bürgerliche mitte in deutschland
sich auf die fdp verlassen kann mit der
fdp wird deutschland nicht nach links
rücken mit der fdp wird deutschland
vorangehen jetzt haben sie viel gesagt
was nicht geht mit ihnen jetzt auch noch
ein bisschen ausloten was geht zwischen
ihnen und den grünen herr lindner sie
haben heute gesagt eine art fortschritts
freundliches zentrum könne gebildet
werden darunter kann mir vorstellen
können sie das ein bisschen mit leben
füllen und zwar mit konkreten leben
bitte ja gerne es ist ja eine tatsache
dass insbesondere die jung und die erst
wähler grüne und fdp gewählt haben haben
wir beide unsere stärksten ergebnisse
das ist ein auftrag der jungen
generation unser land zu modernisieren
vielen geht es dabei etwa um den
klimaschutz und die fdp möchte beiträge
dazu leisten dass wir ein
digitalisiertes
klimafreundliches land eine technologie
nation werden und dafür brauchen wir
private investitionen dafür brauchen wir
eine beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
für die offenheit für unterschiedliche
technologien ihre sicht aber haben die
grünen gesagt da sind wir dabei
wir stehen am beginn von gesprächen aber
wir sind uns im ziel einig dass
deutschland seine klimaziele erreichen
muss und ist ja bekannt daher sie was es
wäre jetzt für niemanden interessant
wenn wir nochmal die wahlprogramme uns
gegenseitig öffentlich vorhalten wenn
wir das tun würden jetzt geht es darum
zu schauen wie können wir die ziele die
geteilt werden bestmöglich erreichen und
etwa bei einem technologiegetriebenen
klimaschutz geht das vielleicht wäre
deutschland gut beraten wenn wir
zukünftig von einer sozialökologischen
aber marktwirtschaft sprechen und über
den klimaschutz nicht in eine stärkere
starts zentrierung gekommen wenn dann
noch eine kurze frage zum schluss bitte
diese diese richtung ampel heute
zumindest erst mal ist es das politische
ende für armin laschet
es gibt von uns keine festlegung auf
eine koalition aber zur situation der
union bitte sie um verständnis kann ich
mich nicht äußern christian lindner der
fdp-chef danke fürs gespräch bitteschön
und beide gespräche haben wir aus
termingründen kurz vor dieser sendung
aufgezeichnet jetzt ein erster
nachrichtenüberblick heute mit
sicherheit energie technologie die
europäische union will auf wichtigen
gebieten eigenständiger werden das haben
die staats und regierungschefs
beschlossen auf ihrem gipfel in
slowenien weiteres zentrales thema war
die mögliche aufnahme von sechs
balkanstaaten
die eu verspricht den potenziellen
beitrittskandidaten
gesamthilfen von knapp 30 milliarden
euro verlangt dafür aber grundlegende
reformen auf einen zeitplan wollten sich
die gipfelteilnehmer nicht festlegen
hoffnung auf einem bein schritt machen
sich bosnien herzegowina serbien
montenegro der kosovo albanien und nord
mazedonien
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen und lkw
chef wähler haben dazu aufgerufen sich
sowohl gegen cupid 19 als auch gegen die
grippe impfen zu lassen beides
vergangenes jahr so gut wie keine grippe
gegeben habe sei das risiko einer
gefährlichen welle dieses jahr größer so
wieder außerdem seien zum winter hin
steigende corona zahlen zu erwarten
impfungen könnten vor diesem hintergrund
helfen eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
im missbrauchs komplex münster ist eine
32-jährige mutter zu sieben jahren und
neun monaten haft verurteilt worden
obwohl sie wusste dass ihr sohn schwer
sexuell misshandelt wurde habe sie
nichts unternommen so die richter damit
habe sie sich der beihilfe durch
unterlassen schuldig gemacht bei der
frau handelt es sich um die
lebensgefährtin des haupttäters der
bereits zu 14 jahren haft mit
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
verurteilt worden war in einer
gartenlaube hatte er auch andere kinder
vergewaltigt zusammen mit vier weiteren
männern
nordrhein westfalens justizminister
spricht von einem paukenschlag gegen die
organisierte kriminalität bei einer
großrazzia allen niedersachsen bremen
und nrw haben mehr als 1400 beamte
zahlreiche beweise und luxusgüter
sichergestellt elf menschen wurden
festgenommen
ziel war ein geldwäsche netzwerk zu dem
auch islamistische gefährder gehören
sollen die beschuldigten sollen 140
millionen euro verschoben haben ins
ausland und zurück ihnen werden noch
weitere straftaten vorgeworfen darunter
geiselnahme raub oder drogenhandel
wurde der jüdische musiker gil ofarim
antisemitisch diskriminiert das versucht
jetzt die leipziger staatsanwaltschaft
zu klären
in einem video hatte offering berichtet
er sei beim einchecken in ein hotel
aufgefordert worden seine kette mit
einem davidstern abzunehmen einer der
beschuldigten mitarbeiter erstattete
inzwischen anzeige wegen verleumdung
kurz nach dem mutmaßlichen vorfall
demonstrierten hunderte menschen gegen
antisemitismus
mein kollege armin wolf der das
abendliche nachrichtenmagazin im
österreichischen fernsehen moderiert
twittert heute aus seinen ferien ich bin
echt am falschen tag im urlaub das ist
der verständliche schmerz eines polit
journalisten der weit weg ist
ausgerechnet heute ermittler der
wirtschafts und
korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft
durchsuchen heute das kanzleramt in wien
das finanzministerium und die
parteizentrale der regierenden
konservativen svp neben engen vertrauten
des kanzlers gehört auch der kanzler
selbst zu den beschuldigten der verdacht
sebastian kurz soll die öffentliche
meinung mit frisierten umfragen
manipuliert haben und für ihn günstige
berichterstattung gekauft haben mit
steuergeld unsere nachbarn im süden
erleben einen beispiellosen krimi es ist
schreibt ein magazin die österreicher
fähre aus wien britta hilpert
sebastian kurz ist beim gipfel in
slowenien als zu hause die bombe platzt
hausdurchsuchung im kanzleramt und in
der zentrale der kurz partei cvp es ist
nicht neu dass gegen den hausherren
ermittelt wird bisher ging es um eine
mögliche falschaussage im ibiza
untersuchungsausschuss von neuer
qualität ist aber der heutige verdacht
untreue und korruption auch diesmal sind
es konstruierte vorwürfe wieder mit
derselben systematik es werden einige
sms fetzen aus dem zusammenhang gerissen
alles begann mit dem ibiza video der
spätere vize kanzler strache zeigte sich
darin bestechlich und wie er sich die
presse vorstellt
sagt zack zack einige journalisten weg
positive berichterstattung fertig ist
der wahlsieg die republik war empört die
koalition zerbrach ermittlungen begannen
und der kanzler sagte was aber wirklich
schwerwiegend und problematisch ist das
sind die ideen des machtmissbrauchs die
ideen zum umgang mit österreichischen
steuergeld und natürlich auch das
verständnis
gegenüber der medienlandschaft in
unserem land nun steht er selbst im
verdacht ein ähnliches verständnis zu
pflegen diese kurz freundlichen artikel
in der zeitung österreich so die
staatsanwaltschaft waren möglicherweise
bestellt und gekauft bezahlt mit
scheinrechnungen aus dem
finanzministerium oder durch inserate
mit steuergeld also die ibiza
ermittlungen waren es die auch zu chat
protokollen des kanzlers und seines
umfelds führen sie nähren den verdacht
dass kurz aufstieg auch gelangweilt
umfragen manipuliert inhalte bestellt
waren und weil steuer geld floss
hunderte sms sind es darin solche so
weit wie wir bin ich echt noch nie
gegangen so ein enger mitarbeiter
geniales investment wer zahlt schafft an
ich liebe das sebastian kurz am gleichen
tag danke für österreich heute die
vorwürfe wiegen schwer wenn die
staatsanwaltschaft sie tatsächlich
erhärten kann auf welche weise auch
immer dann kann das sehr sehr gefährlich
werden dann ist das recht verstoße auch
für die koalition
noch sieht man die grünen an der seite
der svp solange die regierung
handlungsfähig ist wie es heißt eine
sondersitzung im nationalrat womöglich
ein misstrauensvotum steht nun an die
opposition fordert kurz zurück und nach
der hausdurchsuchung haben die ermittler
wieder neues material ruhe wird also
kaum einkehren fortsetzung in österreich
krimi folgt
unser nächstes thema der ort war etwa
150 meter lang 30 meter breit und gut 15
meter tief babin gérard ihnen der name
lässt auch jahrzehnte später noch
schaudern vor 80 jahren erschossen
deutsche einsatzgruppen in der schlucht
dort insgesamt 33
1771 jüdische bewohner aus dem besetzten
kiew die iss hat das genau festgehalten
und so nach berlin gemeldet bis zur
befreiung kiews wurden in der schlucht
insgesamt 100.000 menschen ermordet sie
gilt als das größte massengrab in europa
es ist ein schwerer weg für einen
deutschen bundespräsidenten an diesem
ort und es ist nicht leicht worte zu
finden für das was dort geschehen ist
frank walter steinmeier hat es heute
versucht axel sturm berichtet
gemeinsam schauen sie hinab das st
michaels kloster in kiew der israelische
und der deutsche staatspräsident der
moment mit dem blick auf das bedeutende
orthodoxe bauwerk am nachmittag er wirkt
fast unpassend an diesem tag der dem
gedenken gewidmet ist dem gedenken an
ein vor allem ukrainisch jüdisches
trauma
hier in babij jar ermordeten deutsche
truppen in den letzten septembertagen
des jahres 1941 fast
34.000 jüdinnen und juden
und es waren deutsche die diese gräuel
begangen haben
worte versagen im wissen rund
vorstellbarer grausamkeit und brutalität
an diesem ort bin ja das ist der
holocaust durch kugel unter einem
vorwand treiben deutschen
nationalsozialisten und ihre
kollaborateure im september 41 jüdinnen
und juden durch die stadt erschießen an
der altweiber schlucht babi jar an nur
zwei tagen gruppenweise
33.700 71 menschen das morden dort gibt
noch zwei jahre weiter sinti roma
behinderte menschen ukrainische
partisanen die täter stapeln gleichen
über leichen als die rote armee zum
gegenangriff anrückt versuchen sie ihre
gräueltaten zu vertuschen als deutscher
bundespräsident gehe ich heute vor ihnen
und
verneige mich in tiefer trauer vor den
toten ich bin finde zugleich tiefe
dankbarkeit
für die versöhnung zu der sie lieber
herr präsident sie lenski
so der sie die menschen in der ukraine
zu der sie die nachfahren der opfer von
damals
uns deutschen die hand gereicht
genial da bin ja ist eine gemeinsame
tragödie der juden und der ukraine es
ist die schwarze die hässliche seite der
weltgeschichte berlin kann
fabian ist ein traum vor allem in der
ukraine ein bis heute nur zum teil fair
und aufgearbeitetes trauma weil die
sowjetunion den jüdischen opfern kein
gesicht gab sie nicht als ukraine
benannte
diese schwarze mauer heißt kristall
mauer des klagens ein kunstprojekt als
denkmal neben dem denkmal so wichtig
diese wieder zu machen weil das wird
eine
sicherheit für die zukunft niemals die
fehler der vergangenheit wiederholen
es war kein einfacher besuch für den
deutschen bundespräsidenten dieser
gedenktag in der ukraine
die gedenkstätte babbel hat recherchiert
von den tätern wurden nur einige
offiziere nach ende des zweiten
weltkriegs verurteilt die große mehrzahl
sei zurückgekehrt zu einem normalen
leben historiker vermuten dass niemand
der beteiligten mehr am leben ist und
wir haben jetzt noch mal
nachrichtenüberblick mit käse auch der
nobelpreis für chemie geht in diesem
jahr teilweise noch deutschland über die
auszeichnung da sich der wissenschaftler
benjamin list freuen ebenso wie der
schotte david millar ist forscht in
mülheim an der ruhr mit villen in den
usa das nobelkomitee kürzt sie für eine
methode mit der chemische reaktionen
umweltfreundlicher und schneller werden
mit ihren sogenannten organo
katalysatoren könne man nun viele
produkte effizienter herstellen von
neuen arzneimitteln bis hin zu
solarzellen im zdf sagte liszt was ihn
bei seiner forschung antreibt ich mache
das nicht für die anerkennung ich mache
das nicht um den großen preis zu
gewinnen ich hab's noch nie deshalb
gemacht ich mache das was ich tue weil
ich es liebe und ich liebe diese art
forschung ich liebe es mit diesen leuten
zusammenzuarbeiten die sind einfach
smart und brilliante und arbeiten hart
und ehrgeiz die teil mit mir diese diese
liebe und diesen enthusiasmus für diese
forschung
etliche bankkunden können auf eine zins
nachzahlung hoffen denn der
bundesgerichtshof hat so genannten
prämiensparern recht gegeben es geht um
ältere verträge bei denen banken die
zinsen flexibel angepasst haben was
heißt denn das für banken und sparer
stefanie bareth in frankfurt der bgh hat
heute die rechte von sparern deutlich
gestärkt banken haben nun keine basis
mehr ihre kunden abzuwimmeln denn die
aussichten auf zins nachzahlungen sind
erheblich gestiegen langfristige prämien
sparverträge jahrzehntelang ein renner
und besonders zwischen 1990 und 2010
damals als es noch zinsen gab eine
beliebte geldanlage
doch für banken wurden diese
sparverträge mit ihren hohen zins und
prämien versprechen zunehmend ein
problem
als die zinsen auf dem geldmarkt gen
null rauschten aus diesem dilemma
befreiten sie sich mit der variablen
zins klausel dank ihrer konten banken
die vertragliche verzinsung auf fast
null senken diese art von nach trenkler
nachträglichen zinssenkungen nach
gutsherrenart erklärte der bgh heute nun
für unwirksam inzwischen prüften
verbraucherzentralen tausende von
verträgen und beziffern den
durchschnittlichen schaden auf bis zu
4000 euro pro sparer auf banken kommen
also hohe zins nachforderungen zu
geschädigte sollten aber hartnäckig
bleiben und geduld brauchen geduld und
wahrscheinlich auch starke nerven haben
heute offenbar auch die anleger
gebraucht wenn man auf die tafel hinter
ihnen schaut warum zeigt die dax kurve
so nach unten ja es ist ein mix aus
verschiedenen faktoren die den dax heute
hier ziemlich durchgeschüttelt haben
gleich zu handelsbeginn fiel die marke
von 15.000 punkten zum handelsende
verringerten sich die verluste immerhin
auf 1,5 prozent es ist einfach die
furcht vor anhaltend hohe inflation die
hier umgeht die stark steigenden
energiepreise legen nahe dass die
wachsende teuerung sicht doch länger
einnisten könnte als zuvor gedacht und
dazu der wankende immobilienriese ever
grant in fernost es bleibt also spannend
bahnreisende müssen sich auch eben
regionalverkehr auf höhere preise
einstellen ab dem 12 dezember werden die
tickets um durchschnittlich 1,7 prozent
teurer das teilte der verbund der
regionalbahnen mit auch andere
verkehrsverbünde wollen künftig mehr
verlangen und die deutsche post plant
eine portoerhöhung ab dem ersten januar
sollen für standardbriefe statt 80 85
cent fällig werden der kompaktbrief
verteuert sich von 95 cent auf einen
euro zwar muss die bundesnetzagentur die
pläne noch prüfen ihre zustimmung gilt
aber als wahrscheinlich
es könnte ein durchbruch sein im kampf
gegen malaria die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat erstmals
den flächendeckenden einsatz eines
impfstoffes empfohlen bhp chef gäbler
jesus sprach von einem historischen
moment mit dem aktien könnten künftig
zehntausende junge leben gerettet werden
bislang sterben jährlich mehr als
400.000 menschen an malaria die meisten
von ihnen sind kinder unter fünf jahren
und wie immer mittwochs der blick auf
die lottozahlen auch dieses mal ohne
gewähr
318 27 29 40 superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
zwischen klassischer britischer
gelassenheit und dragset absurdität das
auslandsjournal nimmt uns alle gleich
mit in das land in dem speck und sprit
knapp
und um halb eins bei christina von
ungern-sternberg nochmal auf die themen
dieses tages zum beispiel intensiver auf
dem chemie-nobelpreis eben heute journal
update in allen einen sehr angenehmer
abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nach dem extremen
historischen wetterereignis auf der
alpensüdseite norditalien wo die
regenmenge eines ganzen jahres in 24
stunden runter gekommen ist gibt es noch
etwas regen aber das tief verabschiedet
sich allmählich schiebt noch einmal
regenwolken in den südosten deutschlands
danach wird es immer trockener wir
schauen in die nacht im westen
deutschlands gibt es viele wolken und es
regnet und auch im süden ansonsten gibt
es viel nebel nach norden lockert es auf
und das bei tiefen tiefsten temperaturen
von zwei grad in den ost deutschen
mittelgebirgen und 10 grad richtung
niederrhein morgen einem tagesverlauf im
südosten viele wolken und etwas regen
der verzieht sich allmählich nach
südosten ansonsten lockert es auf und
die sonne zeigt sich vor allem dann nach
nebelauflösung bei höchsten temperaturen
von 19 grad nach norden hin generell in
der nordhälfte milder als im süden am
alpenrand mit zehn grad wird es am
kühlsten sein ja und die nächsten tage
am freitag nach nebelauflösung
sonnenschein vor allem nach norden in
bei 12 bis 19 grad am samstag vor allem
im westen viel sonne bis 19 grad wieder
und sonntag ist es nicht ganz so warm
bei 10 bis 17 grad und damit wünsche ich
ihnen einen schönen abend